HERE STUCKER AND TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HAPPY FRIDAY, WHAT A WEEK.
A LOT GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW, BUT MAY BE THE SINGLE
BIGGEST MYSTERY WHEN YOU TAKE
THREE STEPS BACK IS WHY
DEMOCRATS BECAME SO VICIOUS
AFTER THEY WON.
JOE BIDEN GOT THE WHITE HOUSE,
HIS PARTY TOOK TO CONGRESS, YOU
THINK THEY WOULD BE THRILLED,
YOU’D THINK THEY WILL BE
CELEBRATING, BUT NO.
INSTEAD, THEY STARTED A PURGE.
WITHIN HOURS, DEMOCRATS BEGIN
CRASHING EVEN THE MILDEST
DISSENT.
THEY SHUT DOWN AN ENTIRE
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANY CALLED
PARLER NOT BECAUSE THEY DID
ANYTHING WRONG, BUT SIMILAR
BECAUSE THEY COULDN’T CONTROL
IT.
THEY COULDN’T TAKE THE CHANCE
THAT SOMEBODY ON PARLER MIGHT
CRITICIZE THEM SO THEY
ELIMINATED IT.
THEY ARRESTED A MAN, THROUGH HIM
IN HANDCUFFS BECAUSE HE MADE FUN
OF HILLARY CLINTON ON TWITTER.
THAT MAN IS FACING TEN YEARS IN
PRISON.
DEMOCRATS THEN DECLARED WAR ON
THEIR RIVAL POLITICAL PARTY, NOT
A METAPHORICAL WAR, BUT AN
ACTUAL ONE.
ONCE WITH SOLDIERS AS THE
WORLD’S MOST DOMINANT POWERFUL
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
THEY DENOUNCED THEM AS DANGEROUS
TERRORISTS, LIKEN THEM TO ISIS
AND AL QAEDA.
ANYONE WHO COMPLAINS ABOUT THIS
OR FOUGHT BACK IN ANYWAY WAS
THREATENED THREATENED WITH
EXPULSION FROM CONGRESS.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT DOESN’T
MATTER WHAT VOTERS DECIDED IN
NOVEMBER, IN THE NAME OF
DEMOCRACY, YOU CAN NO LONGER
SERVE IN CONGRESS.
NOR OUR DISTANCE PERMITTED IN
THE ROLE BUREAUCRACY.
WERE NOT OVERSTATING IT, THAT
ALL ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
NOTHING LIKE THAT HAS EVER TAKEN
PLACE IN THIS COUNTRY BEFORE.
THIS IS THE MOST SWEEPING AN
AUDACIOUS ASSAULT ON CIVIL
LIBERTIES IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT ACCOUNTS
FOR THIS?
WHY ARE THEY DOING IT?
IT’S WORTH FIGURING THAT OUT.
ON A MOST BASIC LEVEL, IT’S A
POWER GRAB.
WE SAW THAT FROM THE FIRST DAY,
IT REMAINS TRUE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY DOESN’T
EXIST TO SERVE ABSTRACT
PRINCIPLES OF LIBERTY OR JUSTICE
OR THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
NOR IS ITS PRIMARY GOAL OF
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF ITS
VOTERS IF YOU’VE BEEN TO
DETROIT, YOU KNOW THAT’S TRUE.
NO, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY EXIST
TO ACCUMULATE POWER.
TO SOME IS NEVER ENOUGH, THE
IMPULSE TO CONTROL EVERYTHING.
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO NOW ADMITS THE CHAOS AND TO
MULTIPLY IT IF THAT’S ALL THAT’S
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
THERE’S MORE.
LOOK AROUND.
WATCH AS DEMOCRATS ERECT A
PERMANENT STEEL PRISON FENCE
AROUND THE CAPITAL.
IT’S TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE
INSIDE, TO KEEP THE PUBLIC OUT
OF WHAT WE USED TO CALL THE
PEOPLE’S HOUSE.
THAT’S HAPPENING AS WE SPEAK.
NOTICE THE THOUSANDS OF ARMED
SOLDIERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENTS STATIONED OUTSIDE OF
THEIR FUNDS.
WHAT’S THERE PURPOSE?
WHY ARE HOUSE DEMOCRATS PLANNING
TO USE FEDERAL COMMITTEE FUNDS
TO PAY FOR MORE PERSONAL
SECURITY FOR THEMSELVES?
WHY THE RENEWED PUSH TO SEIZE
FIREARMS FROM LAW-ABIDING
AMERICANS WHO HAVE COMMITTED NO
CRIES, CRIMES?
WHY DOES AOC DESCRIBE HOW SHE
WAS ALMOST MURDERED AT THE
CAPITAL ON DECEMBER 6 QUESTION
MIKE SHE’S NOT ENTIRELY PUTTING
IT ON.
IF YOU’RE SENSING A THEME HERE,
THERE IS IN FACT A THEME.
THE THEME IS PANIC.
FEAR, AND IT’S REAL.
YOU’RE LOOKING AT LEADERS WHO
ARE GENUINELY AFRAID OF THE
PEOPLE THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
LEADING.
HERE’S THE REALLY INTERESTING
THING, THEY SEEM THAT MUCH MORE
AFRAID NOW THAT DONALD TRUMP HAS
LEFT OFFICE.
WITH DONALD TRUMP GONE, THEY
SENSE THAT A PERIOD OF ACTUAL
POPULISM HAS BEGUN, REAL
POPULISM, AND THEY MAY BE RIGHT.
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED THIS WEEK
ON WALL STREET.
A GROUP OF GUYS ON REDDIT
EXPOSED THE ENTIRE AMERICAN
FINANCE ESTABLISHMENT AS A
CORRUPT AND FRAUDULENT SCAM THAT
IT OFTEN IS.
THAT’S A PIVOTAL MOMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
ONCE YOU SEE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, YOU CAN’T UNSEE IT.
ONCE SOMEONE PULLS THE MASK FROM
YOUR FACE, HE STILL REMEMBERS
HER FACE.
PEOPLE’S ATTITUDES ABOUT OUR
ECONOMY WILL CHANGE FOREVER
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED THIS
WEEK.
IT’S A BIG DEAL.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S
RESPONSE TO WHAT HAPPENED THIS
WEEK?
THEIR FIRST IMPULSE WAS TO BRAG
ABOUT HAVING THE FIRST FEMALE
TREASURY SECRETARY.
THAT’S WHAT THEY SAID.
THAT’S NOT AN ADEQUATE RESPONSE
TO WHAT HAPPENS.
EVEN THE BIDEN PEOPLE KNOW THAT
IT’S NOT.
THAT’S ALL THEY HAD.
IF THE TRUTH IS, OUR LEADERS
DON’T HAVE ANSWERS.
THEY DON’T EVEN HAVE
EXPLANATIONS FOR WHAT’S GOING
ON.
WORSE THAN THAT, THEY THEMSELVES
ARE DEEPLY IMPLICATED IN THE
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS.
IN SOME CASES, THE CRIMES THAT
ARE DRINKING THE COUNTRY DOWN.
THEY KNOW ALL OF THIS.
THEY KNOW THEIR GUILT.
HERE’S THE THING, THEY KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW IT TOO.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE AFRAID.
THEY KNOW WHY POPULISM IS
RISING, AND IT IS.
THIS REALLY IS THE TIME TO MAKE
A DECISION ABOUT HOW TO RESPOND
TO IT.
AND WHAT OUR LEADERS DO NEXT
WILL DEFINE WHAT AMERICA LOOKS
LIKE GOING FORWARD.
IT WOULDN’T BE HARD TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF FIXING THINGS AND
BRINGING ACTUAL UNITY TO A
COUNTRY THAT BADLY NEEDS UNITY.
IN A DEMOCRACY, THE FIRST STEP
IS ALWAYS THE SAME, LEADERS
ENTER INTO A POWER-SHARING
AGREEMENT WITH THE PEOPLE THEY
LEAD.
THEY DO THE OBVIOUS THING, THEY
STOP LYING TO THEIR OWN
CITIZENS, THEY STOP ATTACKING
THEM, AND THEY RESPECT THEIR
CULTURE.
IF THEY DON’T TRY TO CONTROL
PEOPLE’S BELIEFS, THAT’S NOT
THEIR ROLE.
THEY TREAT THEIR OWN CITIZENS
LIKE ADULTS, MEANING THEY TREAT
THEM FAIRLY.
ABOVE ALL, THEY CUT THE PUBLIC
AND ON SOME OF THE FRUITS OF THE
COUNTRY’S SUCCESS.
IF ALL THE BENEFITS OF OUR
ECONOMY SEEMED TO BE ACCRUING TO
A SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE, THAT’S
A PROBLEM, AND THEY TRY HARD TO
FIX IT.
WISE LEADERS KNOW THAT ON EQUAL
COUNTRIES ARE VOLATILE
COUNTRIES.
A NOTE TAX SYSTEMS ARE NOT
CREDIBLE WITH DEMOCRACY.
OUR LEADERS DON’T SEEM TO KNOW
ANY OF THAT.
INSTEAD THEY TELL US THAT SOLAR
CARS AND MANDATORY DIVERSITY
TRAINING ARE THE REAL SOLUTIONS.
NOBODY BUYS THAT, THOSE AREN’T
REAL SOLUTIONS.
THEY ARE SMOKE SCREENS,
DIVERSION TACTICS.
IF POPULISM STARTS WHEN PEOPLE
START TO FIGURE THAT OUT, AND
THEY HAVE CREATED THAT’S WHY
EVERYTHING SUDDENLY FEELS SO
UNSTABLE RIGHT NOW.
ONCE AGAIN, REAL POPULISM IS
BREWING.
IN THE FACE OF ALL OF THAT, THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE ARE DOING THE
SINGLE STUPIDEST MOST
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE THING THAT ANY
LEADER COULD DO IN THE FACE OF A
POPULIST MOVEMENT.
THEY ARE REFUSING TO ADMIT THEIR
ROLE IN THE DECLINE.
FAILURES, AND INSTEAD, THEY ARE
BLAMING THE PEOPLE THEY HAVE
FAILED.
THEY ARE DECLARING WAR ON THEIR
OWN POPULATION.
HOW IS THAT GOING TO END?
IF YOU THINK WE ARE OVERSTATING
IT, WE ARE NOT.
HERE’S THE FORMER CIA DIRECTOR
DESCRIBING WHAT THE ENEMY LOOKS
LIKE BEER TO SPEAK OUT THIS
THREAT FROM DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EXTREMISTS IS MORE CHALLENGING,
I BELIEVE, THEN IT WAS IN TERMS
OF GOING AFTER HER MURDER TERROR
THEY’RE MUCH MORE PERVASIVE.
THEIR NUMBERS ARE MUCH LARGER.
WHEN WE ARE GOING AFTER AL QAEDA
SOUTH OF THE UNITED STATES,
THEIR NUMBERS WERE IN SINGLE
DIGITS OR DOZENS.
IT WAS FINDING NEEDLES IN A
HAYSTACK.
HERE, THERE ARE A LOT OF
HAYSTACKS WITH A LOT OF NEEDLES
IN THEM.
THEY HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL, THEY
ALREADY HAVE THE WEAPONS THAT IF
THEY SO CHOOSE TO USE THEM, THEY
CAN, IN FACT, CARRY OUT THESE
DEADLY ATTACKS.
WE WON SO MANY PROBLEMS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
EVIDENT TO ANYONE’S PAYING
ATTENTION.
THE FORMER CIA DIRECTOR HAS
ISOLATED THE REAL PROBLEM, IT’S
YOU.
ANYONE WHO DISAGREES WITH SUSAN
RICE IS WORSE THAN USAMA
BIN LADEN AND MORE DANGEROUS.
THESE PEOPLE, MEANING YOU, HAVE
THE WEAPONS.
THESE TERRORISTS.
BY TERRORISTS, THEY MEAN TENS OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN CITIZENS
WHO MIGHT HAVE A FIREARM AT HOME
AND DIDN’T VOTE FOR JOE BIDEN.
THEY ARE THE THREAT, AND WE NEED
TO HUNT THEM LIKE WE HUNTED
AL QAEDA.
THAT’S WHAT HE SAID.
IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE A LEADER
SAYING SOMETHING MORE
DESTRUCTIVE AND MORE RECKLESS
THAN THAT ON TELEVISION IN A
MOMENT AS FAR AS THE ONE WE ARE
IN.
IT’S TERRIFYING IN ITS STUPIDITY
STUPIDITY.
THIS ISN’T CRYING FIRE IN A
CROWDED THEATER, THIS IS USING A
FLAMETHROWER IN A CROWDED
THEATER.
WHAT ARE THE IMPLICATIONS OF A
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR TALKING LIKE
THIS?
IT’S NOT GOING TO MAKE ANYONE A
MORE MODERATE, THAT’S FOR
CERTAIN.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
JOHN BRENNAN IS CREATING MORE
EXTREMISTS.
IT’S NOT JUST HIM, ALL OF THE
NEWS CHANNELS OTHER THAN THIS
ONE RIGHT NOW ARE REPEATING THIS
OFFICIAL LINE THAT THE AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT IS NOW AT WAR WITH
ITS OWN POPULATION.
HERE’S CNN’S VERSION.
>> MY COLLEAGUE JIM JUDO IS
COVERING INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM
FOR 20 YEARS.
HE SAYS THE PARALLELS TO THE
DOMESTIC TERRORIST THREAT ARE
FRIGHTENING.
HE POINTS TO RADICALIZATION
ONLINE, DEMONIZATION OF THE
ENEMY TO JUSTIFY VIOLENCE DRUG
TO A CAUSE GREATER THAN
THEMSELVES, DEVOTION TO A CULT
LEADER.
THAT SAID, ARE WE DOING ENOUGH
TO COMBAT THIS THREAT?
SPEAK OF THIS IS THE WAY
LAW ENFORCEMENT LOOKS AT THE
DOMESTIC TERRORIST THREAT AS
EQUAL OR GREATER THAN
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM.
IF WE COMPARE THAT TO A U.S.
POLITICIAN PROPAGATING ISLAMIST
TERRORIST THOUGHT, MATERIALS,
LIES, ET CETERA.
IMAGINE THE REACTION.
SADLY, THERE STILL A PARTISAN
REACTION TO THIS.
PEOPLE ARE DENYING THAT THE
THREAT IS REAL AND THE THREAT
BEHIND THE LIGHT IS DANGEROUS.
>> Tucker: AMERICAN CITIZENS
ARE MORE DANGEROUS THAN FOREIGN
TERRORISTS.
FOX IS SO EXTREME, FOX NEWS IS
SO EXTREME -- NO SHOW ON THIS
CHANNEL WOULD EVER PUT THAT ON
THE AIR, EVER.
IF ANYONE DID, PEOPLE WOULD
RESIGN AND PROTEST BECAUSE THAT
IS COMPLETELY UNTRUE AND
COMPLETELY RECKLESS.
FOR ONCE, WE ARE NOT EVEN GOING
TO MARKET DON LEMON FOR BEING A
MOUTH BREATHER, IT’S MUCH BIGGER
THAN THAT AND IT’S NOT FUNNY.
THEY TOLD THEIR VIEWERS THAT
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN CITIZENS
ARE TERRORISTS.
THAT’S A LIE, FOR ONE THING IT’S
JUST NOT TRUE.
PRESS A LITTLE AND YOU’LL FIND
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY WHICH HAS BEEN AN THING
OF THE DOMESTIC THAT FOR THE
PAST WEEK AT GREAT COST TO
PEOPLE SANITY.
DHS HAS NO ACTUAL EVIDENCE THAT
TRUMP OF VOTERS ARE PLANNING TO
HURT ANYONE.
THERE’S NO EVIDENCE OF A PLOT OF
ANY KIND.
THEY CAN SEE THAT.
TRUST US, THEY WOULD TELL YOU IF
THEY FOUND A PLOT.
THE QUESTION YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF, IS WHAT KIND OF AFFECT
DO LIES LIKE THAT, THE ONES YOU
JUST HEARD CALCULATED TO TERRIFY
YOU, WHAT KIND OF EFFECT DO THEY
HAVE ON THE COUNTRY?
ESPECIALLY OVER TIME, THIS IS
NOT NEW.
WHEN YOU TELL PEOPLE THEY ARE
EVIL BECAUSE OF HOW THEY VOTE OR
HOW THEY LOOK, AND OUR LEADERS
ARE DEFINITELY TELLING THEM THAT
EVERY SINGLE DAY, WHEN YOU TRAIN
A POPULATION TO TALLY AMERICANS
BY RACE AND ETHNICITY FIRST AND
FOREMOST, KEEP TRACK OF PEOPLE’S
GENETIC BACKGROUND EVERY TIME
YOU SEE A PICTURE -- REALLY?
WHAT EFFECT DOES THAT HAVE
PROMOTE GROUP IDENTITY EVEN AS
YOU INTENTIONALLY DESTROYED
NATIONAL IDENTITY?
IF YOU DO ALL OF THOSE THINGS,
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY DO YOU GET
AT THE END?
YOU GET A SCARY DIVIDED COUNTRY.
AT THE KIND OF COUNTRY WHERE YOU
NEED STEEL FENCING OUTSIDE OF
THE NATIONAL LEGISLATURE.
IT’S VERY OBVIOUS WHERE ALL OF
THIS IS GOING, AND IT’S VERY,
VERY BAD.
PART OF THE SOLUTION IS TO STOP
TALKING LIKE THIS IMMEDIATELY.
NO MORE AGING SPIES AND CABLE
NEWS DECLARING WAR ON AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
DOMESTIC POLITICAL ENEMIES MORE
DANGEROUS THAN AL QAEDA, WHAT?
NO MORE POWERMAD MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS DIVIDING PEOPLE BY RACE
SO THEY CAN CONQUER.
WHITE FRAGILITY, WHITE
SUPREMACY, THOSE ARE RACIAL
ATTACKS, STOP LYING ABOUT IT.
WE SHOULDN’T TALK THAT WAY IN
PUBLIC.
OF THOSE ATTACKS ARE MAKING
PEOPLE CRAZY.
BY THE WAY, OVER TIME, POSSIBLY
MAKING PEOPLE DANGEROUS.
FOR REAL.
THE TWO THREATENED, TOO NUTS.
WATCH THIS CLIP AND ASK YOURSELF
WHAT KIND OF EFFECT THIS WOMAN
IS HAVING ON THE UNITED STATES
RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE THERE ARE LEGITIMATE
WHITE SUPREMACISTS SYMPATHIZERS
THAT SIT AT THE HEART AND CORE
OF THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
THERE IS NO CONSEQUENCES FOR
RACE HOOPLA
RACISM, NO CONSEQUENCES FOR
INSURRECTION.
IN NO CONSEQUENCES MEANS THEY
CAN DONATE.
WE ARE NOW AWAY FROM ACTING OUT
OF FEALTY TO THEIR PRESIDENT
THAT THEY HAD IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
AND NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
FEALTY TO WHITE SUPREMACIST
ORGANIZATIONS AS A POLITICAL
TOOL.
>> Tucker: LET’S JUST BE
HONEST FOR A SECOND, THAT WOMAN
IS A TOOL OF CORPORATE POWER
POSING AS A TRUTH TELLER.
A LOOK AT HER CURRENT, CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS.
WHO IS SUPPORTING HER CAMPAIGN
QUESTION WHY PEOPLE WANT TO
CHANGE THE SUBJECT AWAY FROM
ECONOMICS TO IDENTITY POLITICS.
AT THAT WHOLE POSE IS FRAUDULENT
IN HER CASE.
LISTEN SPECIFICALLY TO WHAT SHE
SAYS, AND THINK ABOUT THE EFFECT
ON THE PEOPLE LISTENING, PEOPLE
STANDING IN AIRPORTS WILL HEAR
HER SAY THAT.
FEALTY TO WHITE ASSIST
ORGANIZATIONS AS A POLITICAL
TOOL.
WHAT DOES THAT EVEN MEAN?
WE ARE NOT SURE WHO SHE’S
TALKING ABOUT.
APPARENTLY THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND ITS GRAND COLECO KEVIN
McCARTHY OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT’S NOT TRUE, BUT IT’S WORSE
THAN THAT.
THIS IS A FANTASY, A DARK
FANTASY DIDN’T TELL MIKE
DESIGNED TO TERRIFY PEOPLE AND
MAKE THEM EASIER TO COMMAND.
OVER TIME, PROBABLY NOT LONG
NOW, IT WILL HAVE OTHER MORE
INSIDIOUS EFFECTS.
TALK LIKE THAT FROM OUR LEADERS,
FROM OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS IS
GOING TO TURN SOME OF OUR
CITIZENS VERY, VERY RADICAL.
HE DON’T WANT TO LIVE IN A
COUNTRY WITH A VERY, VERY
RADICAL PEOPLE.
TO BE CLEAR, WHATEVER YOU HEAR
ABOUT FOX NEWS BEING RADICAL, WE
WANT TO LIVE IN A COUNTRY THAT
LOOKS LIKE -- I DON’T KNOW,
2005.
WHERE RACE IS NOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING ABOUT YOU, WHERE
YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO GET AHEAD
BY PLAYING BY THE RULES --
THAT’S CALLED MODERATE.
THAT’S CALLED DEMOCRACY, THAT’S
A REPUBLIC THAT WE WANT.
TALK LIKE THIS, WHICH IS